[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
remember when there were so many games
released in february and march that we
didn't know what to play first well
april is nothing near those heights so
this may be a good month to catch up on
those older games that said there is a
handful of games and a few free ones too
which dropped late last month which you
should be aware of so let's do this
first up is lego star wars the skywalker
saga all nine entries of the mainline
movies are recreated in their lego
likenesses the other star wars spin-off
movies will be added over time as dlc
right away there's over 300 characters
from the series to be collected and used
the game is set with each trilogy
available from the beginning so you can
select which story arc you prefer first
anakin luke or ray there's 45 levels in
total which should keep you busy for
quite a while we've been told combat has
been updated to include a variety of
combos for force users and a new
over-the-shoulder shooting mechanic for
blaster moments what can i say it's more
lego star wars after all these years you
either love it hate it or just accept it
lego star wars the skywalker saga
releases on april 5th on playstation
xbox and pc
you know it's a slow month when a sports
game is this early in a video this is
mlb the show 22. like all annual sports
games you've either already made the
plan to buy it or you couldn't care less
mlb the show is one of those unique
games which is made by sony and
playstation yet it's releasing day and
date on xbox game pass make of that what
you will if hitting a ball with a stick
and catching it with an oversized glove
is your thing you should grab mlb the
show 22 on playstation xbox and twitch
on april the 5th go spots
okay let's do some free stuff
this month is very playstation focused
and once again starts with a new battle
royale over on the ps4 is live or die a
20-player battle royale with a twist the
premise sees the world in chaos
scientists have told us that for the
planet to survive only five percent of
humanity can come with it this begins
the process of battle royale survival of
the species there are three game modes
to choose from survival hunting and good
old no frills battle royale hunting mode
is not about eliminating your opposition
hunting mode is all about who can hunt
down the creatures on the island the
person with the most points at the end
takes the victory survival mode combines
standard br with that hunting mode
eliminating the ai controlled dinosaurs
and other fantastical beasts and
warriors and also being aware of other
real-life players will try and
third-party you at every opportunity be
the last survivor with the most points
to win the game so three ways to play i
haven't played this game yet and i was a
little worried about the frame rate in
these trailers right now so i watched a
few streams and i can safely say it has
a much more stable frame rate when
you're actually in game like you'd
expect it will run better on ps5 than it
does ps4 and it's definitely not a
polished game but sometimes we just want
something different to play if anyone
has played this please give us some
feedback in the comments below
is it worth our time
[Music]
your next free game is again on ps4
which of course can be played on ps5 and
it's also on mobile and pc2 this is
bleach brave souls a mobile game which
is trying to break into the console
market in 2022 so before downloading
this you should know it's a gotcha loot
boxes random rewards it can be
infuriating to some and embraced by
others and it's possible to play without
touching these at all bleach brave souls
is a real time action game with beat em
up mechanics and rpg elements the core
loop is acquiring new collectible items
and leveling them up to use in-game
rinse and repeat it looks like the
impact of the anime series and the doors
opened by gentian impact has led to
bleach brave souls coming to console
will you try it oh i did a little
digging and the mobile version has over
40 million player download since release
and on pc the steam version has a user
rating of very positive with many people
commenting on how addicting bleach brave
souls is
yikes
[Music]
your next free experience is again on
ps4 and pc and acts like a way to get
you to buy ghostwire tokyo there is a
short prelude an interactive story that
can be downloaded right now corrupted
case is a typical visual novel we've
seen over the years it's really here for
those who want to know more about the
ghostwater tokyo law and the random
disappearance of almost everyone in
japan it's a very short experience about
20 minutes long for the average person
and it's not for everyone but if you'd
like visual novels you'll be happy with
this it's free right now last month i
told you that ps plus subscribers can
download gta online for free on ps5 that
offer is still here and i thought i'd
take this time to remind you of a trick
if you don't yet have a ps5 by using the
mobile phone app you can add free ps5
games to your library even if you don't
own one yet this trick is useful because
ps5s are like rocking horse poo hard to
find
[Music]
okay let's transition out of free to
play and onto free updates here's some
dlc for a paid game you may have picked
up last year one year ago return dropped
a bullet hell survival horror outing and
now there is free dlc which is crazy
impressive the update adds a two-player
mode completely changing how the game
plays and on top of that there is a new
tower of sisyphus mode an endless battle
that gets harder and harder as you climb
the tower if you'd like to be challenged
and take on the rest of the community
this free update is worth your time and
i still can't believe this is free it's
a huge update
[Music]
another game with a dlc this month which
isn't free is back for blood tunnels of
terror update left 4 dead fans rejoiced
when that team released the spiritual
follow-up back for blood this update
brings two new cleaners new underground
dungeons filled with new types of
zombies to battle through a new pve mode
ridden hives arrives too giving fans
tons of new things to do some of the new
warped enemies look fresh out of
resident evil it's great april 12th is
the release date on playstation xbox and
pc
[Music]
i'm probably showing my age now but back
in 1999 a role-playing game named chrono
cross released it received a perfect 10
out of 10 score on gamespot back when
that meant something and went on to sell
over a million copies and now over 20
years later it's back in the radical
dreamers edition releasing on ps4 xbox
one pc and twitch radical dreamers by
the way was a text-based game which not
many people know about but that's been
added to the collection too this may not
sell fantastically well but it's a great
way to bring a truly great rpg to a new
audience let's see if it ages well
[Music]
and finally i'm going to mention a game
made by one guy slipstream yes this is a
terribly slow month slipstream is a
retro outrun style racer with a cool
gimmick rewinding time so if we take a
corner too quickly and mess things up
completely we press rewind and change
the future with 20 tracks and
multiplayer supported with split screen
this could be a good past time first
released on pc three years ago it
finally comes to console on april 7th on
playstation xbox and the switch so
that's april's offerings any you fancy
playing i'm gonna try that battle royale
game on ps4 and see if it's worth your
time and i might jump back into back for
blood what about you oh and let's finish
with a silly question like we always do
which is the most beautiful console
you've ever seen i think today i would
say the n64 i'll see you in the comments
i'm adam you're awesome see you next
time
[Music]